it is now my distinct honor  to introduce the chief justice of the  supreme court of the united states  john roberts to administer the  presidential oath  to the next president of the united  states  joseph r biden  ladies and gentlemen please stand for  the oath of office followed by musical  honors  please raise your right hand and repeat  after me  i joseph robinette biden jr do solemnly  swear  hi joseph robinette biden jr do solemnly  swear  that i will faithfully execute that i  will faithfully execute  the office of president of the united  states office of president of the united  states  and will to the best of my ability to  the best of my ability  preserve protect and defend preserve  protect  and defend the constitution of the  united states constitution of the united  states  so help you god so help me god  congratulations mr president  [Music]  [Applause]  let's get it  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you